good morning Hank it's Tuesday and Here
I am in beautiful Florida Here I am in
beautiful Florida ever does get old I
still find this funny I don't know if
they do oh it's very hot something can I
heard a family reunion in Seaside
Florida the world capital of teenagers
who don't know who we are what's it like
well it's been like this basically
[Music]
I got these for Henry but they were too
big hi John what are you reading
Endymion nerd yeah yeah did you and you
got one whole star so Hank we're here in
northern Florida and yes I'm wearing an
inner tube that just sticks to my body
because you know my belly is too big you
don't need a bigger team it's all the
tube you need it's just like the
Internet how is it just like the
Internet
we've always want bigger tubes you know
in these thoughts and places videos I
always try to draw out some tortured
metaphor but that's the worst one yet do
not shake your hair this close to the
camera Justin Bieber it burns doesn't it
burn it burns
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you the younger brother but their
marriage continues to be an inspiration
to me I'll see you on Friday